nothing could have prepared the
residents of this german village for
what happened here
for the torrent of water that engulfed
and destroyed their properties
the water has receded now but has left
much of shult in ruins
in home after home they are clearing up
and trying to take in the scale of the
damage
how far did the water come this year
margaret radamacha takes us into the
house she's lived in for over 16 years
it's an absolute catastrophe
there are many people who've been
affected many houses don't exist
the full extent isn't yet known flood
water shattered building after building
insult
residents have lost their lives and
power failures overnight
left many frantically trying to contact
their relatives
andreas muller had to wait hours to
learn his in-laws were safe
overnight they were upstairs and it was
dark because there was no
no light no no power and
um yeah there was also no phone
connections that we tried to
reach them all night and it was very
hard to get them
the house they've lived in most of their
lives is uninhabitable
everything on the ground floor destroyed
and every neighbor around them is
confronted by the same
awful reality people here had expected
flooding but say they never imagined the
sheer
force of the water that burst through
their village destroying homes and
businesses
and leaving hundreds here without power
gas electricity
and clean water but the rain and the
floods have impacted way beyond
this corner of germany
homes in eastern belgium are also
underwater after record levels of rain
some properties are now too dangerous to
stay in it
luckily i have my sister but now we've
been told that our house could collapse
and so we've had to leave
leticia collins shows us how far the
water rose inside her property in
enversal
eventually her family were forced to
leave
around 4am the waters started rising
from over there
i told my partner and we were able to
move the car out and quickly move a few
things upstairs
but then we had to go as the waters rose
so quickly inside the house
as we left the water was up to here on
me
roads and transport links have been
affected across a wide area
and with already sodden ground the worry
is about more rain to come
and what that could mean for many
thousands of people
michelle clifford sky news germany